welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down
Loki season 2 episode 5 is now here and
it's packed with lots of tiny wely
wibbly wobbly stuff that we need to get
into throughout this video we're going
to be going through the Easter eggs
hidden details and all the things you
miss to explain what it is exactly going
on with the show so grab that jet ski
wave goodbye to your all life and let's
get ready cuz we're past the point of no
return and I don't mean spaghetti he
past that point anyway uh last week saw
docks getting put in a box like sniper
Wolf's Instagram story we also watched
as the temporal Loom exploded in the
wake of Victor timely's untimely death
seemed like it was all going to come
crashing down but as this episode shows
us it wasn't the
end now the entry is called science SL
fiction and it basically gives us the
life stories of the characters from the
TVA huge shout out to Simon a bman on
Twitter for pointing out that this of
course references OB being a science
fiction writer but it actually has a
deeper tie of time travel George McFly
was also wning Back to the Future and
beyond that we have a big reference to
another film that is The Rocky Horror
Picture Show with Loki's time slipping
being like the time warp if you think
I'm reaching then don't be a sum ofmer
[__] because the first song in that is
also called science fiction now we begin
with the Erie music over the top of the
Marvel Studios logo came into 2001 Space
Odyssey which itself took place across
time and showed the evolution of
humanity that also had an alarm siren
like what we start off with with the
monolith providing a signal that reached
out across the cosmos you've got a full
breakdown of the film if you want to
check it out but we open up with Loki
who's clearly time slipped to a time
before the loom exploded the Marvel
Studios logo itself also explodes at the
end which looks very akin to how the
temporal Loom exploded too time slipping
is again a major thing in this entry and
we watch as he wonders the empty hols of
the TVA before starting to drift I
absolutely love the shot that we get of
him in a doorway and it showcases the
box that he's sort of been trapped in
however he manages to escape it come the
end of the entry by controlling the time
slipping and basically going where he
wants to he also breaks the bootstrap
Paradox Loop but at the moment he is
stuck in it and the TVA itself has very
much been a prison tomb with him
constantly being pulled back to it
either due to Duty or because he's held
captive from here he warps out in front
of the TVA elevator and catches a man
looking at the manual now this is a shot
that was shown all the way back in the
first trailer that has lowkey time
slipping in the back whilst the other
reads the manual it just brings things
full circle to show the cause and effect
of things and seconds later we see the
scene playing out from the other
perspective gives us lots of tiny wely
wibbly wobbly stuff and at this point
things get spaghettified which I'm
guessing is when the loom exploded in
the past now this spaghetti effect is
something that's been Lac throughout the
season but it also appears a lot in the
greater MCU during Quantum Mania we
watched the giant man get turned into
this and Reed Richards was also ripped
apart like this when w turns Sous storm
into a single mother both these moments
start with reality with wand's hex
Powers being linked to that too I think
what we're seeing is the destruction of
reality in all these cases with things
being ripped apart at a molecular level
that's why the effect was with them too
and why Marvel keeps reusing it unless
it's their new favorite plugin however
them looking like strands that also
shares the iconography of how timelines
them M themselveses look which links
into how everything sort of becomes
thread-based this ties back to the
sisters of Fate who too looked over
lifelines which were represented as
threats looms are also apparent there
too and thus we have all these things
connecting because it's all connected
now as per usual we get the title
sequence but where things change is that
the letters slip out before coming back
this is a really cool effect that pretty
much highlights the time slipping that's
going on in the entry the letters
themselves could also stand for the
group who get Tak taken away and then
come back now last week I theorized that
the show was happening before the event
of quantum Mania and that the Council of
kangs we saw was actually a result of
this right after the video dropped that
actually got confirmed with the release
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
official timeline book it now has
endgame happening and then Loki season
one and two off on its own Branch
timeline while the other Disney Plus
shows and MC movies continue alongside
it that means that the Multiverse being
open like this has Creed the council and
all of the members that we see in it at
the end of quantum Mania now that takes
us in a theory time the time I've lost
the
time now I think that this is likely how
he who remains was created whether
that's with Victor or someone else I
think that he who remains knew he could
only be created through a branch
timeline and this could only be achieved
through W Kang thus he sent raavana back
with a book to give this to Victor
knowing full well that this would lead
to the loom exploding and leave the door
open for his arrival he who remains had
to be credit through a branch timeline
and this could only be achieved by
things happening with Victor in the
comics Kang's name is Nathaniel Richard
but these other versions may be the ones
that helped to make him this also
explains why that was classed as the
sacred timeline because that's the one
that has Victor on it all the other
timelines were pruned originally but
this was left so that he who remains
could be created leading to the events
of the show playing out this could then
lead to more branches with all the kangs
convening to get what we have in Quantum
Mania due to the Mis minutes message
thanking people for their service it's
becoming obvious this was all part of
the plan you don't write a message
thanking people in their death if you're
not fully aware that that's probably
going to happen anyway so
[Music]
end anyway from here we cut to a prison
which is revealed to be a branch
timeline in which Casey was a prisoner
at Alcatraz this prison scene's actually
based on a true story with it being
about the three men who managed to
escape the prison this was adapted in
the Clint Eastwood film Escape from
Alcatraz and was also used as the
Baseline for the story in the rock or
the rock sh as it's pronounced in that
movie anyway in the film they used to
fake dummy to make the gods think they
were in their beds like what we have
here Casey's called Frank like Clint
Eastwood's character and they also bring
across the iconography of the poster
with people popping their heads out of
holes well so not a true story yeah just
the the films what I think of when I
think of that true story now it was
believed that the three drowned swimming
across the bay but as their bodies were
never found the mystery of what happens
still lingers on I always saw case he
was an upstanding guy but I guess not
mate I guess not seriously man you and
me we're [__] done professionally I
like ly moving through the empty Halls
we watch as they do that thing too with
it being clear that this Branch was a
time in which they managed to escape we
then get the line let's go hurry up if
they catch us they're going to cut us
like fish which is a call back to this
give me the Tesseract or I'll gut you
like a fish Casey what's a fish found
that hilarious and also huge an out ofit
from the streamer for theorizing that
back in episode three and I love this
reveal I know I've done that theory a
lot of times about them being from
Alcatraz in the videos but yeah Brit was
the one who found it so shout outs to
here now Loki arrives alarming everyone
and he ends up time slipping as they try
ship the boat out cing to the McDonald's
from 1982 this is obviously where Sylvie
ended up going to at this point Loki
Wars to her wacky waving inflatable arm
flailing Tube Man wacky waving
inflatable arm flailing Tube Man wacky
waving inflatable arm flaming Tube Man
love the kind of mirror we have with him
also waving his arms about which happens
with our two and just kind of brings the
two things together now this location is
of course the jet ski shop and if you're
from England then you might recognize
the place this is actually Ace Cafe
which has been done out to be the
workplace of our favorite TVA agent they
do a lovely coffee tea a biscuit and
Crump it for 50p on a meal deal and all
you have to do to get this is go in and
use the code Ace spoilers for 50% off
now if you're also feeling generous and
want to support the channel and get
something get something else out of it
not as good as is The Crumpet but uh
check out our merch store below right
underneath the video we're currently
selling a lcky inspired t-shirt along
with our classic movie breakdowns one
and a couple more from all your favorite
franchises if you're feeling extra
generous then please hit the join button
to get early access to our videos for
just 99 p a month only for you Mr Jacobs
because you're a number one customer
this place is also called piranha pow
Sports which I couldn't find a business
for before June 2023 however piranhas
are of course known to eat things which
might be a reference of the timeline
eating itself anyway from here Loki
slips to time theater 25 which is a
location I believe that popped up during
the first episode it's here that he came
face to face with his future and saw how
everything he did would lead to death in
misery everyone sort of tied back to
their own Origins story and this being
where he warps to it's it's pretty much
his was probably one of the defining
moments for this version of the
character in which he decided to go out
and help people huge shout outs to Mt
but he pointed out that this is also the
first place at the they ever did time
slipping in the series because of the
whole time twister thing now speaking of
helping people we learned that Hunter
B15 is actually a doctor and this makes
a lot of sense when you look at her
character she started off as someone who
was cold and cruel willing to wipe out
entire timelines because she deemed it
fit however after Sylvie showed her some
of her memories she's clearly changed
and has become a warmer and more
welcoming person who wants to keep all
her timelines active B15 will of course
have taken the hypocritic oath meaning
that she has to protect all life no
matter what I think this personality
slowly starting to seep back in was
Muran Mobius who too long to be back
riding on a jet ski get that man a jet
ski anyway this is back in 2012 out New
York which is a big point in the MCU
2012 in New York was when the Battle of
New York happened which was of course
caused by Loki I'm kind of wondering if
in the end all the characters will be
returned back to this point and Hunter B
15 could be going back to her death
however she might also be a person that
helped countless people that day so
maybe maybe her going back would be
something that needs to happen now it's
also quite ironic cuz she tells the girl
to stop climbing trees and trees have
branches which he's been pruning as part
of the TVA you see what I'm saying it's
all connected now we get a brief glimpse
of Loki and see m is on top of jet ski
to some 80s music and learn the man's
the dawn when it comes to selling jet
skis also I know people have their own
names in these timelines but I'm just
going to keep it simple and and stick to
their TVA ones ultimately in the end
that's what they choose to go with and
it's kind of sad seeing all the lives
they had even got free donuts at work
and as we know the man loves desserts at
the automat now mbius is alive during
2022 which means that he and his kids
survived the snap however as we learn
his wife is gone however maybe it was
the fact that she was taken during this
I'd love it if in the end he returned
back to her and found she'd been brought
back so he could be with his family now
mobus being a jet ski salesman is
something people have been theorizing
about since that first season and and
I'm so glad they brought it into the
show knowing all that ins and outs would
explain why he was obsessed over it and
it' also show the memory raising doesn't
completely wipe everything out there's
still that little part buried in the
back of your mind that will keep you
longing for it and though you know you
keep wiping it out it it's still going
to be there think deep down Mobius knew
that he was happier in his real life and
this is why he didn't go back and look
at himself because he knew it would pull
him away from his judies to him that's
all he really knows and it makes him way
more complicated than what could have
been a very one-dimensional character
now Mobius also talks about an ATV which
according to Google's a quad bike that
turns into a jet ski sorry I uh was more
interested in a dirt bike didn't even
know they made them what what the hell
mate make make sure you watch all the
ads on this videos you schmook cuz I'm
definitely going to buy one you CHP see
you CH now from here we cut in 1994
where we see Obie picking up the Zartan
contingent which is a book that's
actually appeared in the show before
this pops up during the season 2 credits
sort of of setting up what was going to
happen here not really setting it up but
you know what I mean this could
potentially be nottin spelled with an X
who in the comics were created by the
celestials now though he's down on his
luck he still has his bubbly personality
and we learn that he's the one who's
been buying his own books man hasn't
been selling well though and thus he's
been sticking his books up in stores to
try and gain some good word of mouth I
also love how it has his photo in the
back of it and as we see he got to put
one in the manual which everyone reads
so it's a nice little touch on that
living out in the wilderness he's sort
of like how he is at the TVA and
shuffled off away from society and this
also brings us an image from the credits
2o as we see the Post-it notes up in
them from his home turns out these are
all ideas he's jotted down so stuff like
the felaxi calendar it all makes sense
also shout outs to Mt again he noticed
that the who is circled and as we know
who becomes a big thing later on now I
instantly recognize this room as being
ob's office with all the stuff taken out
of it you can even catch the male shoot
up at the back highlighting where this
actually is there's also two big fans at
the back which somewhat resemble the two
windows in her's office they themselves
had little spirals in them that look
like the spirals showing it's it's all
Conn I actually kind of wonder if this
was where the TVA was built out from
with this being the only real world
location that exists both here and at
the TVA this is pretty much where things
all get kickstarted from from a certain
point of view temporally so yeah this
being the Nexus The Hub the headquarters
whatever you want to call it makes a lot
of sense that it also exists in the real
world now we can also see equations up
on a chalkboard potentially setting up
the chalkboard and equations we could
catch in he who remains his Citadel he
has so many inventions scattered about
the place too and it's pretty much
exactly the same as what you'd expect
from the character instantly sucked into
his story Obie believes Loki straight
away and that's because of how dull his
real life is man has poured all of his
imagination into his books which we see
still has lots of copies lining the
place he says the sons of yur is his
most popular book of all time which we
can say that there's piles and piles of
kind of hope that when this all comes
crashing down that he ends up returning
home and writes all about the TV this
could be its own best-selling novel
which is similar to what omn man did
with his books on Earth although he
writes failed science fiction books he's
still a genius and Loki's desperate to
control his time slipping which he does
throughout the entry this is sort of the
power of a god of time hinting out where
I think things may be going he's
basically the living version of a temp
Pad but at the moment he he can't
control any of it now if the TVA can't
be saved then it's all going to go crazy
and Kang's war is going to take over the
Multiverse and the way the show seems to
be operating as a whole is that it's a
Time Loop within a Time Loop however it
does seem like it gets broken at the end
potentially this is all part of its own
time Loop two with Loki's predetermined
path being that he breaks time and then
puts it back together wrapping around
like this it seems like it could be
creating its own orboros which as we
know is a never ending cycle oroboros is
a snake that eats its own tail and this
creates an infinite cycle of death and
rebirth that we've seen playing out it's
very much what's going on with the show
and what's happened here had to play out
exactly the way that it did because the
TVA is now in its rebirth stages thus it
couldn't have any carryovers from last
time and therefore things had to be
reset I think in the end that it might
be revealed that Loki actually created
the TVA by recruiting all the members
like this and then Kang took over which
is when things were pruned Loki then
died but the version from endgame came
back to the TVA and helped to destroy it
which started this whole thing up again
can we get some toast on Twitter dropped
a great graphic of this based off what
was happening in the new mid-season
trailer that was released earlier in the
week and it makes a lot of sense we have
episodes one and four off in their own
loop with five and six probably being
off in their own one too this then all
comes together and breaks both Loops
leading to time continuing in a linear
fashion again as you can see these Loops
creating Ora borrow and potentially he's
the key to stopping this whole thing
there was a reason why he was shuffled
off and why he was the only TVA member
that never had his memory wiped and it
shows that he could be the key to
breaking it all now from here they
decide to get the band back together
literally and this will place their
temporal auras together and use them
almost like coordinates to go back to
that moment in time OB could build a
temp Pad but he doesn't have the
knowledge however the bootstrap Paradox
comes into place with Loy giving him the
manual now fromi could have Don or
Mobius pulling out the bins and we have
a couple of little details like his kids
bike outside the house however if you
look at the window on the top floor it's
also a bed sheet that's dangling out of
it his kids have been clearly sneaking
out into the night and breaking the
rules like my man playing his games on
the TVA computers seriously man you and
me we're [__] done professionally
threads and ropes like this are of
course also a big part of the show so
it's kind of keeping the iconography
connected and just tying it all together
now son Kevin's also been burning
figures and man's like a regular little
Sid from Toy Story this little soldier
looks like a TVA minute man and him
burning it symbolically shows he's in
the front to what his father represents
they your classic little Lads burning
stuff wanting snakes and just being a
nightmare and and reminded me reminded
me of my my two boys I love them no take
take me to the TV mate get me out of
here get me to the TVA quickly please
please anything now ever the salesman he
tries to sell Loki his own personal jet
ski with him then dropping a line that
he said to him back when they first
discussed jet skis with that being two
here I actually think that both Loki and
Mobius will ride out of them and that
could be something that shows up in the
series finale now unlike OB Mobius
doesn't buy the story but his mind's
quickly change when the former arrives
man man actually had a wife and he well
well done not a lot of people do
especially those watching this channel
he hey we're going to have a laugh no
not me though I've got a wife uh but
yeah take take take me away take take me
to the TVA I'm just kidding did well for
myself didn't I to be fair I don't know
how I did it h but it wasn't through
spoiling movies or TV shows but I
appreciate the sport cuz it makes me
look famous on YouTube anyway I love how
we have Loki basically recruiting
everyone for the TVA and he probably
made the organization that ended up
trapping him this is its own bootstrap
Paradox 2 with him being stuck inside
this constant Loop of time now though he
promises he can bring Mobius back as we
see that isn't the case I think he
probably will in the end but you can see
why they ended up wiping his memory all
these lives would probably pull agents
back and thus they stole the memories
from them to continue them as slaves B15
is also recruited along with Frank who
we see arriving at the shore again it
kind of explains where the real Frank
went to and it's such a cool scene
that's filled with slow motion shots of
the group together hey put that back now
in the end we go back to the McDonald's
which is where we see Sylvia in reality
disintegrating around her unlike the
rest though she's managed to keep her
memories and they head out to discuss
what's going on at this point we cut to
a z IC arcade machine which you might
remember as being the movie that X5 made
already done a big video breaking down
the character from the comics so if you
want to check that out then check out
our episode 2 video the cliff notes are
that zc was a movie star 2 who was fused
with his costume and possessed by a
demon the credits actually end with this
line you died insert your coin loser
which a nice way to end things cuz
everyone's kind of lost their lives now
long story short yet but the story of
people's lives what makes Sylvie think
that she he should just let the others
have theirs Mt did a big video about how
the explosions basically its own
multiversal big bang with the reset
button now being pressed I kind of feel
like these timelines might be getting
wiped out by Kang and he recruited all
the agents before things Came Crashing
Down he's basically enslaving people
that he was going to kill anyway and
just bringing them from the destroy
timelines so they can work for him
forever and they talk about it like it's
caused and effect but in reality it's a
chicken and next situation this is
actually them being recruited so the TVA
can be started again rather than it
being when the TVA is ending now syby
keeps asking Loki why he wants to save
the TVA and in the end it's because he
just wants his friends back guy's
basically being lied to his entire life
and this is what ended up turning him
into a villain finally though he's
managed to meet people that he loves but
in the end he's just a man out of time
this conversation is also all about
choice and after ordering her drinks the
bartender says excellent choice Sy the
back of the room we see it starting to
look more like it is in the TVA with the
colors getting closer and the Clutter
piling up shows OB is messy everywhere
and I was actually pretty surprised
Mobius didn't try C Casia jety it's the
perfect Escape item anyway Loki returns
deflated and tells them to go home which
is when we could across to Sylvia at a
record store here we see a monkey figure
and you might recognize this as being
from the credits too mug there says take
me which in the end Sylvie kind of wants
to happen and at this point we get a top
down view of a record player which
symbolically holds a lot of meaning
record spin in cycles and after their
stop they can then start back up again
records also go in predetermined paths
and play the same thing each and every
time much like how this series is one
big loop this in itself is an AA boros
further adding to the themes and the
player itself surrounded by circles
created by the knobs and lampshade now
this top down shot is all subili with
how we see selie sat on the self out
almost like like a God's eye view of a
god it lets us know that time is the
true God in all of this and that at the
end of the day it's the main power in
every Universe listening to oh sweet
nothing by The Velvet Underground this
tells the story of Ginger Brown homeless
and all out of love this sort of reflect
selvie who's now just drifting through
life endlessly but the song also
mentions others that have nothing as
well reflecting the group that's slowly
being assembled I actually wondered if
this person entering the door was lowy
and he may also have been the one that
ended up taking that coffee cup in the
end this could be showing that in the
future Loki will go back and see Sylvia
at this point before reality collapses
and he'll stop it from collapsing and
get to spend time with it hope hope that
makes sense H but in in this version at
least the reality Falls around them and
I love the camera work that we see in
this scene everything just flows
brilliantly and we focus on the record
spinning around the room before closing
out in the end she uses he who remains
wrist device which he's kept hidden for
for all this time going to the meet up
she says the branches are dying and th
there's no real choice and they have to
act finally they're together but the
happiness doesn't last long we see his
reality falls apart around them
including all the people in the end Loki
manages to slip back through time
without changing things thus breaking
the bootstrap Paradox once and for all
and freeing himself of the loop that
he's been trapped in no longer is he on
a predetermined path and we sees he's
able to alter things in the past he says
that it's about who who which might even
be a nod to he who remains and in the
end he warps back to where the time Loom
exploded however now he's conscious with
his knowledge from the future and knows
how to handle things and do things
differently now the credits also contain
some brand new shots including mobus son
a jet ski and a prison mugshot these
just have two faces on them and they
don't have Casey showing that the other
two got caught whereas he didn't there's
also the record too and yeah nice nice
little additions now for the next part
of the video I want to give some my
predictions for next time and how I
think the series is going to wrap up
this will be talking about things shown
in that mid-season trailer which
actually spoils a fair bit of the series
if you don't want to know then please
turn off now because there's a couple of
clips and one bit of the comic book
artwork that could spoil the whole thing
anyway I believe we're going to get the
reveal that there's actually a Loki
behind he remains who was not only
controlling him but also everything in
the series this has given a bit of a
hint to us in the trailer when we see
the time stream appearing green which
then lead directly into to Loki himself
it was also a piece of leak comic book
artwork to promo the show that had Loki
walking down the stairs holding the
Strand showing that he's now in control
of the time stream this has a lot of
basis in the comics and in the agent of
Asgard Rod we saw as L he was trying to
change his fate throughout time he'd
been a loser that had been used to boost
people up which is something also
touched upon during Loki season 1
however he changed things and eventually
at the End of Time encountered an older
version of himself which was known as
king Loki King Loki was the one who was
actually in control of everything and
him being outside the loop would make a
lot of sense now Josh atena nerds did a
big video covering this and he brought
up a lot of really interesting points I
could highlight where things are going
to go in case you don't know Kevin fagy
recently got promoted at Marvel and he's
now in charging not only the films but
also the comic books as well this means
that Kevin can control the story lines
in both and actually set things up for
the MCU that also appear here Joshua is
talking about how he thinks that lowy
might actually be Avengers Prime who who
exists at the end of time and basically
rules over everything he's currently
collecting Avengers for a big battle
which may hint to where things are going
with Secret Wars if they bring this to
the MCU then Loki could be the one who
ends up going around collecting Avengers
to fight against K and this would be
such a flip on his character who
initially brought them together by being
a threat this is a motif that is sort of
teased here too with them very much
doing the same thing to the agents
throughout their lives it's also
possible that he designed the TVA and
rary pointed out the similarities
between the bridge the bifrost it has
some design motifs that pull directly
from it perhaps showing that Loki
actually had a hand in making it someone
had to be the one who gave he who
remains a script of what happens and
thus there has to be someone who remains
that remains longer than he who remains
also we get a shot with Loki walking
along the bridge without a suit on and I
think he's able to survive this because
the character is a god he's going to
have to be one and we also watch him
guiding he who remains who in the end
fails to change things I think he thinks
he is who but but in the end the who it
has to be Loki anyway that wraps up the
episode and huge thank you for watching
up until this point as I'm sure you know
the Marvels is out next week and it's
going to be a bit weird covering both
this and Loki at the moment it's out in
the UK on the Friday so we're probably
going to cover Loki first and then go
see that hoping that nothing in it
completely contradicts what we say about
the show's ending but I'm just letting
you know in case you're wondering what's
going on we are trying to get a
screening for Mt to go check it out
earlier but just in case you're
wondering where it is and and how we're
doing them anyway leave your thoughts on
the episode below and also what you
think's going to happen in the finale
can't wait to see what happens in it and
thank you again for all your support
over these last five weeks really means
a lot knowing you guys are riding with
us and I really appreciate all the
support now if you want something else
to watch we've got the Gen V finale on
screen right now so definitely head over
there right after this out the way huge
thank you for sing through the video
I've been your host Paul and I'll see
you next time take care peace